joe biden is desperate to move on from
the crisis that he created his own
making in afghanistan and frankly
everywhere else hasn't even mentioned it
since last week now his poll numbers
have never been lower and he is
desperate for a political win well first
he tried to shift the focus to covet 19
announcing his brand new clearly
unconstitutional
vaccine mandate during a nasty speech
where he was scolding and vilifying half
the country but with infections spiking
nationwide biden's poll numbers
surrounding the pandemic they're also in
the tank tonight so today he tried to
shift the focus once again this time he
targeted corporations and millions of
americans according to biden just aren't
paying their fair share
okay top 10 percent pay uh 90 of the
bill anyway i wonder if this includes
zero experience hunter who's reportedly
being investigated but not paying taxes
is hunter included joe now regardless
biden's remedy a massive tax hike or tax
hikes in order to raise funds for
something democrats are now calling
human infrastructure in other words big
government socialism from welfare to
child care to medicare to more obamacare
to pre-k to day care to free college to
college tuition forgiveness all in the
name of climate change
you see climate change as defined in the
swamp as swamp jargon that equals
socialism now of course any tax hike on
corporations you will pay that that will
be passed on to the consumers and the
inflation from any massive spending bill
that will hurt lower income americans
the most in fact after this year's
reckless federal spending of biden wall
street journal is reporting quote for
the lowest paid americans real wages
adjusted for rising prices fell 0.5
in august uh that is a dramatic decline
people are paying more for energy to
fill their tanks with gasoline to heat
and cool their homes and they're paying
more for every product they buy in every
store because it costs more to ship it
there that means the spending power for
lower income americans went down their
salaries were essentially slashed
because of biden's policies but today as
per usual you didn't get the truth from
joe biden instead we get a whole lot
hacking and coughing i don't know
biden's been battling this mysterious
illness for weeks take a look
i'm not sure you know it
but if you didn't know what you should
meanwhile
meanwhile
for these republican governors
it isn't about public health
about the health of the people it's
about politics mississippi
and children are required to be
vaccinated against measles and we can
continue to do it
and covet
the data shows that overwhelming
majority of americans agree with my
proposal
that's there's no surprise
we're also going after the bad actors
and pandemic profiteers and our economy
the amounts that come into their bank
accounts and what amounts
go out of their bank accounts
joe it's called recall uh you might want
to get some it works i use my voice four
hours a day but don't worry jen sake
claims that her boss joe biden is
totally fine healthy as an ox if that's
the case the ox may need medical
attention and of course biden's coughing
fits are not unprecedented maybe no one
in the history of american politics had
a worse cough than failed presidential
candidate hillary rodham clinton it was
getting pretty bad then when she fell
down at ground zero that was even worse
take a look
i've been talking so
too much
[Applause]
i don't know i have my own suspicions
anyway we are happy that hillary
eventually got better even though she
will never fully recover from her
humiliating defeat of president trump
but for what it's worth at least hillary
could usually remember names and dates
and was not the complete cognitive mess
that joe biden is this week yet another
example joe couldn't remember the name
of australia's prime minister during a
meeting with australia's prime minister
take a look
thank you over to you mr president
thank you
boris
and i want to thank
that fellow down under
thank you very much pal appreciate it mr
prime minister
um thank you boris and my
that guy from down under the guy for the
record joe he's the prime minister his
name is scott morrison i think we can
see
you know why vice president harris
frequently conducts all these meetings
with foreign leaders instead of biden
and of course she does have plenty of
time biden's borders are kamala has done
absolutely nothing to fix the crisis at
the southern border now this is a scene
at the border look at your screen over
the past 24 hours four thousand migrants
crossed into texas were apprehended by
border patrol including many
unaccompanied children on tuesday night
two babies rescued by border patrol
after they were abandoned right in the
middle of the rio grande and as you can
see the situation is so dire that texas
governor greg abbott attempted to shut
down six points of entry with mexico and
then the biden administration blocked
his efforts so far this year in the
middle of a pandemic more than a million
and a half illegal immigrants have been
apprehended and then processed and
allowed into the country from the
southern border including over 200 000
alone in the month of august and a lot
of them are put in those overcrowded
biden cages in the middle of a pandemic
with a high rate of covert positivity oh
and by the way they're not tested uh and
there's no vaccine mandate and then they
are dispersed to the rest of the country
many were coveted this is
essentially officially now the biggest
super spreader event in human history
and the financial and human toll is
extreme joe biden doesn't seem to care
in fact joe biden hasn't said one word
about the border crisis in over a month
and breaking tonight according to our
own bill mollusion we showed you this is
drone footage from fox news the faa they
just implemented a flight restriction
over this international bridge right
there trying to prevent fox's drone from
showing you the american people the
truth and capturing images just like
this in other words the faa is being
used to cover up for biden's failures
we're going to let that stand i don't
think so hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else